Kim Kardashian queen of the selfie has
taken her best talent to the next level
I just pose away and take about 300
photos until I get the perfect selfie
the reality stars releasing a 352 page
book filled with photos she's taken of
herself but he's not alone young people
love taking selfies lots of them and the
media thinks we're the worst pretty much
the most narcissistic people on the
planet strictly self-absorbed and
narcissistic and take photos of
themselves generation of self-absorbed
self promoting self-involved over shares
so while the selfie loathing I mean
after all ever since they've been
cameras they're been selfies allow me to
give you a brief history of the shelfie
the first ever selfie was taken by
Robert Cornelius in 1839 Martin Van
Buren was president and the civil war
wouldn't happen for another 20 years
after that people pioneer different ways
to take selfies selfies were snapped
during World War two the Kennedys took
selfies and in the 1970s Andy Warhol
used Polaroids to take artsy photos of
himself but where did the word selfie
come from well in 2002 an Australian guy
first used the term online when he
busted his lip after falling down the
stairs at a friend's birthday party
drunk of the mice 21st he wrote landed
lip first I'm sorry about the focus it
was a selfie now everyone from President
Obama to a listers to the Pope take
selfies celebrities can give their fans
glimpses into their fabulous lives and
everyday people can well pretend to have
fabulous lives teens and Millennials
take the most selfies up to millions of
selfies every single day and some
surveys have found that nearly half of
American adults have taken at least one
selfie and it's an international pastime
- the number one selfie city makati city
in the Philippines
Tel Aviv and Milan are up there too and
Kim
you better watch out cuz in Thailand
there's a woman who has over 20,000
Instagram posts almost all of them
selfies so is there a downside to all
this selfie sharing well some people see
selfies as a symptom of low self-esteem
and a recent study found that men who
share selfies show higher signs of
narcissism and psychopathy while the
study didn't include women it's
researcher expects the same results
apply to everyone but some are flipping
the script on selfie Hey they say
pictures of yourself aren't a
narcissistic but empowering Katie
Warfield a college professor and
self-proclaimed lover of selfies so that
selfies are a chance to reclaim your own
beauty especially in a society that
dictates what Beauty should look like
one way selfies were used for good was
in March of this year when black people
across the world tried to black out
social media and fill up everyone's
feeds with selfies of color and let's
not forget that selfies which are
records of our own lives can also
document some pretty amazing moments
like the time this guy survived a plane
crash or when astronaut Aki hoshide took
the first selfie in space that said we
could all probably do without this one
so what do you think our selfies a form
of self-expression
or just vain please for likes and
retweets let us know
so maybe we're the generation of selfies
you always